hola qué tal se trata de gustavo
cárdenas era uno de los exdirectivos de
circo la filial de pedevesa en eeuu que
se encontraba detenido en venezuela
junto a otros cinco compañeros desde el
año 2017 en febrero de este año se había
ratificado la condena de estos
directivos se les impusieron penas entre
8 y 10 años de cárcel y tal y como lo
decías luego de este encuentro el pasado
sábado entre representantes del gobierno
de joe biden y de nicolás maduró junto a
jorge rodríguez y la primera máquina
flores pues se conoce esta liberación no
es la única se habla también de que
estaría siendo liberado también jorge
alberto fernández un turista cubano
americano que fue detenido en venezuela
en febrero de 2021 por portar un dron en
el estado táchira y se le había acusado
de terrorismo también una acción
inmediata luego esta reunión fue el
anuncio a nicolás maduro de reanudar el
diálogo con la oposición en méxico por
lo que no queda duda que estos pasos que
está dando en nicolás maduro autor de
esas negociaciones entre ambos gobiernos
y se podría esperar no solo próximas
liberaciones sino también otras
concesiones por parte del gobierno
venezolano que es hayan sido pedidos por
el gobierno de eeuu a cambio de que
pueda venezuela ayudar con el suministro
de crudo luego de que eeuu decidiera
imponer sanciones en esta materia rusia
y brevemente daniela ante rusia como
enemigo mayor eeuu se podría ignorar la
situación en venezuela a cambio de
petróleo
analistas coinciden en que no se trata
de que ignoren la situación de venezuela
sino que ha sido una jugada estratégica
por eeuu a conveniencia sin duda
económica por el tema petrolero pero no
ha sido una carta blanca tampoco hay
condiciones sobre la mesa la renovación
del diálogo en mexico para que haya unas
elecciones con condiciones en venezuela
en el año 2024 una de ellas y consideran
que también es una estrategia de eeuu
para presionar al gobierno de nicolás
maduro a que se cumpla con esto y más
adelante quizás también otras
liberaciones políticas pero por supuesto
a cambio también de negociaciones en
materia económica